Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 17th, 2017 what's going on?
How? Why? Yeah,
July 17 2017 I'm going to go play that number number.
That shit ain't maybe you still do it.
Always remember that.
If all of a sudden you know somebody's got something like a receipt or something
and there was a couple of same numbers,
that's what I'm going to play.
I'm going to go down there and play it on the mega bucks.
That's what they had in Massachusetts. Mega Bucks. My favorite one,
best name ever for any lottery I thought was set for life.
That was just the perfect phrase.
Every blue collar working stiff.
That's what they want to just fucking set for life.
Sit sitting there having a fucking beer checks rolling in.
Don't gotta worry about nothing. Set full life, right.
Cause if you work in class, you, you,
you work paycheck to paycheck and it becomes a fucking grind
set for life. Dude, I could fucking sit right here,
right? I could fucking sit right here.
Do just fucking staring at my fucking toes and I still got that check coming in
every month for the rest of my life. You know why kid?
Cause I'm set for life. Yeah.
About Mikey Dody hit the fucking set for life. He's fucking set for life.
Kid doesn't have to do shit fucking cock sucker. Um,
God bless them. Um, anyways,
I'm in a great goddamn mood. Why?
Because I got eight hours sleep last night despite the fact that my daughter is
at my daughter, um,
just waking up and she's trying out her voice now was [inaudible] remember when
Mariah Carey used to hit those really high notes? She's doing that.
And every time I look over like, oh my God,
she's just looking at me and she has like her legs in our are,
everything's like up in the air and she's smiling at you.
It's like impossible to get upset. You just start laughing.
So actually riffing about that this weekend in grand rapids going out,
I wonder if that works as an adult,
you cut somebody off in traffic and they look over at you a few.
Some are flexible enough where you could just put both arms and both legs in the
air, just give them that fucking baby
grin.
That might've been the creepiest image I've ever, I've ever thought of.
There you go. It would just creep them out and be like, oh my God,
should that guy even be driving?
I think there's something wrong with them in a mental department there.
Um,
so anyways, I want to thank everybody that came out to the, uh,
the shows at the Fountain Street church in Grand Rapids, Michigan.
Um, it is, and it is continuing to be one of my favorite gigs I've ever done.
Um, I know I always
say I'm going to put up pictures. Like I didn't put up a picture of my drum,
like I said it was
going to, and I'll tell you why because you know,
I got these simple stands and the ones that I want,
I just wanted the single bracket ones. I don't like those double bracket.
Like I'm going to go play in a fucking hurricane.
They weigh 9,000 goddamn pounds. Um,
I accidentally ordered those instead of the ones I wanted.
So I had to return those. And now today I'm going to pick up the right ones.
I just want to have it all set up. When you see it, I want you to see it, right?
I want it to have the fucking right look. I'm not going to have it. Like,
you know, here's the car I bought and I don't have this, the fucking,
the tie is on it. So, um,
but speaking of drums, um, my booking agent,
my Ruben Kincade is, uh, you know,
is tell them how much fun I have when I go on the road.
If I find a place where I can go play drums, he goes, you know,
we could put it in your rider that, you know,
anytime you do a couple of nights at a theater, they could set up a drum kit.
There. I go, get the fuck outta here.
That sounds like some diva shit he goes to. And he goes, dude,
they have music acts there all the time. It's no big deal.
So I was like, all right,
so I show up at the Fountain Street Church and uh, they had a fucking,
they had this Yamaha kit with this fucking horrific white trash,
like leopard skin rap. I don't know what the, I don't even know what to call it.
It was like somewhere between the stray cats way back in the day and a
poison maybe, you know,
it actually looked like the fucking stretchy pants that the slutty girls would
wear it, they have your metal concerts. It was the same kind of print.
And I'm looking at those things going on like, what the fuck are these?
And she goes, don't worry. Everybody always says that. Sit down and play them.
And the kick sounded amazing and I was able to thanks to my drum teacher,
you don't have a game plan.
When I try to tune something up and I got this snare to sound great and um,
I went and on those fucking hilarious,
I go in there on Saturday to play and I'm like about an hour before the doors
open. So I went in there and I was fucking wailing on him.
And when I got off the kit, I, you know,
I w I was literally like in like the place with the priest dresses and shit,
you know, puts on all the fucking flow flowing ponchos and shit.
And I walked out and there was no one in the church and I walked in the parking
lot and there was like fucking six of the security guys just standing out there.
I was like, sorry, sorry.
It was still a lot would have been great if they actually had them out on the
stage. I would have left them there for the show, wouldn't have bugged me,
but uh, it would have sounded fucking unbelievable. Um,
this giant church and I didn't realize because, you know,
last time I played there only played one night. It kinda came in town. I did it.
I was like, what the hell was that? That was fucking incredible.
And then I left. But um, this time I was there for like,
uh, two days, three nights, and I was able to read up on like the history of it,
listen to this shit. This is all the people that perform there.
Because there was no bigger venue that was the biggest venue in the,
uh, I guess western Michigan or whatever, or at least in grand rapids.
So if anybody big came there, they went there. Everyone,
Winston Churchill spoke there.
Helen Keller spoke their blind and deaf,
learned how to fucking read and write and speak, somehow figure that one out.
Um, who else? Uh, Amelia Earhart, Malcolm x.
Did I say Winston Churchill? Duke Ellington, Ella Fitzgerald,
Dave Brubeck, led Zeppelin, pink Floyd.
You too. In like 1984 played there.
I think Zeppelin and pink Floyd was obviously on their first tours. And, uh,
that's just,
that's just what I can remember trying to picture when I was looking at the
wall. Who Else I saw there? I mean, it was fucking incredible.
Eleanor Roosevelt,
and they had like pictures of them and then like the little thank you notes and
shit. It was fucking ridiculous. Uh,
BB King and then make,
I think I said that in the video that I took,
which I will actually post and I promise you, I'll give you a picture of my, uh,
my drum kit, uh, this week. Um, so anyways,
we are on to episode two of F is for family. We're recording the first one.
Just remember this,
just remember me telling this recording the first one on Jay,
July 18th,
2017 you wait to see how long it takes before you fucking see it.
Fucking animation man takes forever.
Um, but anyways, let's let me talk about, uh, what should I talk about here?
How about this? How about how great fucking grand rapids is?
And it's one of my favorite cities.
I was there with Dean del Ray and he was fucking murdering all week and yet he
hit a bunch of fans, came out to people flying in to see him,
and then he went on to Detroit to go play some rock club like after, uh,
after our show Saturday night. But there was this place, I of course I've post,
forget the fucking name of it. Um,
but they had all these old video games in there. The fuck was it called?
And why is my stomach still growling? I had a bowl of cereal
trying to stab myself before the fucking acting gig. I'm, oh by the way,
thank you for all you guys suggestions,
sec slash criticism of my dieting or whatever. This guy goes,
dude, you can't say you're crushing it. You know, you crushed it.
If at night you still having a drink or two, it's like, hey,
you fucking don't realize that mom. Yes, I realize that.
Um, but anyways, uh, what was it called?
Stella's assumption. I can't fucking remember. But, uh,
we went down there and they evidently they had a great burger,
which I didn't have went to this healthy place and got this fucking rap right in
a water water. And then, uh, we went over there,
they had all these pinball machines and shit and me and dean,
a fucking oldest shit. And we walked in there,
they only had one pinball machine, but they had all these great, um,
old, uh, video games and we showed up. Right.
And we sounded like two fucking kids. D just goes, they got asteroids.
I think we blew 10 bucks play in that. Um,
I've never been one of those guys. Never been a video game guy.
Just haven't been, cause they're so fucking awesome. They were like addicting.
But that is something I remember back in the day when you would watch MTV cribs
and then like these fucking people would have these video games in their, uh,
in their houses. And, uh, I saw a distinct,
like I always feel like he buy those and then you never fucking use them. Mike.
He use it for like the first day and then it's just like, oh wait,
I gotta go to work. You know, I have to work so I can pay for this big giant,
stupid machine that I could've just pumped a couple of quarters into and let
somebody else own in deal with the fucking maintenance. How,
if I was ever going to buy one, it would be asteroids.
And my number two is a game that not a lot of people know about.
And um, I think for the most part they've all disappeared.
Uh, it was a fucking great game. At least I loved it.
It was called elevators and it was basically, it, I,
if I vaguely remember it, it was like spy versus spy kind of thing.
You were dressed in white and all the bad guys are dressed in black,
almost kind of looking like dressed like despite our spy from a mad magazine.
And you had to say,
you get in an elevator and on each floor they were these bad guys.
And as you pass the floor,
they'd be shooting at you from the writer to both from the left and yet to get
all the way up to the top of the building and get something and then come back
down again.
And the worst was when you were going back down again and you'd be shooting at
the guy and the guy would duck any lay down on the floor. And as you went by,
when you couldn't raise your gun up and it was just your head at floor level,
he'd blow your fucking brains out. Um, I used to play that one.
I buy either one of those, I guess. No, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't as fucking wasted money.
But I'll go whenever we had a great time and I got to kill a picture of dean and
his total fucking Rockstar pose, play in the game. And,
uh, I think he already tweeted it out.
So if you look at Dean Dell race Twitter thing, you can find that shit.
So we did that and I want to thank people at Dr Grins Comedy Club.
I went down there and uh, did a quick spot,
you know, went up, did some jokes or whatever.
And it was funny when Dean was up there,
he fucking started trashing this woman who is sitting in the front row cause she
wouldn't shut up. And I said to the other comics, go, they're gone. I've like,
it's one of those deals as a comedian,
you'll be on stage and someone's talking and commenting on your jokes and then
you don't realize most of the crowd can hear it.
So if you're kind of supposed to ignore it, I guess,
even though it's driving you nuts. So he just fucking snaps and trashes.
Or when I was sitting in the back of the club,
I said to the other comedians like, you know, it's funny, we
couldn't even hear what she said. Um,
he probably should've just kept going. I go,
I've made that mistake 20,000 fucking times.
Then I went up next and I did the exact same thing, exact same thing,
and I fucking trashed her. And then she got mad, you know,
said she was offended by,
for some fucking joke I did about the troops of some shit like that. It's like,
no it isn't. No it isn't. I know when you got offended, you fucking EGOMANIAC.
When I looked at it,
I said something to the effect of why would you think that you have anything
interesting to say was one of those lines, which was just really, you know,
now that I've said it out loud and I've kind of gotten out of the emotion,
it was a, I was really mean and went mean. That's what I did.
I went fucking mean. Um,
so anyways, oh, by the way, somebody tried to scam me.
They tried to scan all freckles. Well,
you think you're dealing with here so fucking red,
bald Ralph malf look motherfucker way you are.
That doesn't mean he can scam me though. They almost did.
If I wasn't so fucking paranoid. Um,
I'm hanging in the hotel and I get this phone call and I pick it up and it's
just this computer going, oh,
that saying that they were calling from apple and that there was a problem with
my iCloud and somebody might be breaking into it and they go, you know,
call this number, blah blah, blah, blah, blah. And I'm like, Oh,
you gotta be fucking kidding me. So I started and they say the number twice,
I can't remember it.
So I just start taking a guess and I punched in like out of the, you know,
10 numbers, you know, one, eight, eight, eight, whatever. I got about six in,
in an immediately starts dialing and I somehow get connected now, right there,
that should've like tip me off that these people are just fishing,
looking for somebody to react to it.
So I dialed like six other fucking 10 digits I needed. And then this guys,
I got low Dah, [inaudible] Dah. And I was like, yeah, you guys just call it.
Well what is this referring to? It was like, you fucking called me,
it's about my soundcloud or whatever. And they go, Oh yes, yes,
you have a security problem, a bomb. And I go, well,
who's fucking fault is that? I go,
why did you guys set up the cloud if it wasn't going to be like safe,
now you've exposed me all this shit because what I fucking
cause I downloaded the royal blood fucking album.
Now all of a sudden somebody is going to drain my bank accounts.
You computer cons. I wasn't Carson,
but I was flipping out and then he goes, so sir, we can help you.
We can help you over the phone. We just need to access your computer. I go,
you mean access my computer? And the guy just starts talking. I go, I go,
I don't want to do that over the phone. He goes, sir, this is a very,
this is a secure fucker, blah blah blah. And I go, well how do I, how do I know?
Cause you say so basically I wouldn't fucking do it just because I was looking
at, I was looking at them like they were legit, but I was just like,
well you already got hacked. Why the fuck would I go with you again?
Why don't I just go ahead the
store. So literally got to the point, he goes, sir, this is,
this is a secure Bababababa. And I just kept going like, well,
I don't even know who you are. You just for,
I know you're one of the guys fucking trying to hack into my computer, dude.
I literally felt like I was in the Bourne identity.
You know when you don't know who to trust, you know,
and you just fucking yelling at the other guy, go, you put your gun down,
you put your gun down first, right? Hmm.
So finally Tiki gives up on and he goes, so here's your case number and a,
you know, I'll fucking, you know, he said some dumb shit.
You've been to Turkey or Jordan recently. It's like,
no, no.
I saw the 30 for 30 on Len bias when he fucking went one-on-one against Michael
Jordan. You, you call in Michigan, you fucking asshole.
So anyways,
he ends up transferring me and it just fucking hangs up. And then I'm like,
flipping the fuck out.
So I called the guy who produces my fucking show and he just goes, why? He goes,
yeah, apple doesn't call anybody. He goes, Nah, man, that's just bullshit.
So thank God I'm a paranoid jackass or I might've let something happen there.
So I'm just putting that out there. Let you know.
I'm sure all your young guys know what it is and you feel so smart and you're
going to shake your head and laugh your ass off at me on Twitter going,
hey, Fuckin oh do you know like it's 2017 on.
I learned that back in 2010
did ya?
What else did you learn how not to play a guitar and then still call yourself a
musician? I'll bill. Oh, Bill Cumberland. Let's not be the old guy here. Huh?
I gotta be honest with you. Uh,
del Ray played me some of that Scrillex guy stuff and I fucking really liked it
and I thought it was way different than anybody else.
And that's what I'm learning. Whenever something new comes out,
as much as your old ears listen to it and say, what the fuck is that?
You just have to know that there's going to be the fucking,
the Jimmy Hendrix, the Richard Pryor, the Tom Brady, the James Brown,
the fucking would they, cause it's going to be,
you gotta find out who that person is of the thing that you're listening to and
then you can judge it. Okay? It goes by, I swear to God,
it goes right back to New York pizza. All these fucking dopes.
Get off the fucking plane, the first place. That's his famous New York pizza.
They eat it and then they go, this pizza sucks here. It's like, no,
you didn't go to the right place. Okay. You didn't go to the right place.
And um,
DJ's are like New York's pizza in that fucking everybody thinks they can do it,
you know, and everybody's claiming that they're the real fucking deal.
And everybody saying they're famous. Everybody's famous Ray, the fucking DJ.
And um, I actually, I really liked to, shit, I was like, you know what?
I could actually fucking get in the car and drive, listen to this shit.
Especially at night, like this great.
Like driving songs like the Who Eminence Front,
who we a one when a bunch of fucking money playing poker.
That's it just gets your leave getting
your car by yourself,
the fucking window down and you listen to that songs.
You drive up to the desert ted screen, one of the top five moments of your life.
Oh fuck you. I'm old. Anyways,
what else? What else did I want to say? Oh,
did you guys watch all the Mayweather?
McGregor pressers as they call them, oversees the press conferences.
It kind of the same thing over and over again with Conor McGregor.
He just kept going like, what the fuck?
What the fuck is wrong with you? He's got on a fucking tracksuit.
That form Voltron thing was dumb and I loved when he trashed him on that,
but I will tell you this,
watching all of those people showing up for a fucking press conference,
they sold at the Barclays Center. They sold out with like the maple leafs play,
I believe in Toronto.
The staples centered people showing up to watch a fucking press conference.
I can tell you this, oh, cynical. Bill's going to ruin the paper view for you.
Those press conferences are going to be better than the fight, you know,
and the fucking people that are going to order that God damn fight of the same
fucking people that slow down on the highway to watch somebody change a fucking
tire, um, date. It's like,
it's just beyond. It's beyond a spectacle and a people go like, hey,
you know, I know it's a spectacle, but you know what? Just get just your,
a word to booking words. Um, yeah, I know I'm getting fucked in the ass,
but hey, what do you see? What it feels like
[inaudible]
though, that paper view can go fuck itself, Dude.
They're riding on the same plane over the fucking London.
Get the fuck Outta here and all this shit McGregor gives may whether there's one
topic he completely avoids cause it would fuck with ticket sales,
which kind of makes him part of the fucking bullshit of that whole thing.
You know what I mean? It's just get the fuck outta here. I gave them,
I've given that guy enough fucking God damn money giving them enough fucking
money. I've gotten fucked enough. I've gotten fucked enough by that guy, Wade.
Like it's professional. Boxers can't lay a fucking hand on him and I'm,
I'm fucking not enough.
By the eighth round as he's Poo poo poo pointing them to fucking death. Um,
now he's going to fight a guy who's not even a bar who used to box.
I love they used to box. Yeah. There's a lot of people used to do stand up.
You want to see them do an HBO special. Um, here's the bottom line.
If they ever met each other in a bar and started swinging and McGregor would
fucking kill him,
he'd take him to the ground and then the Mayweather would know what to do.
So they've eliminated all of that. We know, Bill, you've said that.
So I don't know. Um, anyways,
maybe McGregor's, I mean,
Mayweather's ego maybe tries to knock him out and I'm just not,
I'm not going to fucking watch it. I'm really, I think what
I'm going to do is I'm going to get out on the highway when the fucking fight is
on and just cruise down the highway doing 90 miles an hour.
Just looking around going like, this is what it should be like.
Like if I was running shit,
this would be the level of people that were in the world.
I was joking on my aunt this weekend in grand rapids
saying,
you know what I would do if I was running shit on the night of the Mayweather
McGregor fight, I would turn all the buffalo wild wings into gas chambers.
All those fucking mouth breathing morons that were jerseys, you know,
with other men's names on the bag. Oh all day, dude. I called it,
all of those guys just, you just gone.
All of them gone and you'd watch. I bet. I bet the, the main,
the level of maintenance on, on, on the Internet would go down.
You know
these five, by the way,
these fucking people now who just sit there and they watch CNN or Fox all day
long and then they show up to you and they just start vomiting out all this
fucking fearful shit that they just watched.
And then after they do that and get you all stirred up,
they don't even have the decency to offer a fucking solution.
All these fucking morons. It's just like,
why would you sit there and watch Fox News all day? Easily.
That's all you're going to do. Watch a little CNN balance out. You fucking lies.
Keep yourself level fucking what's his face?
My buddy was telling me this weekend, you know, it's got to,
global warming is going to get so hot,
you know the saying they're not going to be able to fly planes on a LaGuardia
and I'm the, and I'm eating. I'm thinking like, oh,
how the fuck am I going to be comedian anymore? You know? And then that was it.
He didn't offer any fucking solutions. He just let me know like, Hey,
in the future you're going to be able to do your job.
And then I'm starting to fucking think about, you know,
me and my family living out in the street. All I want to do is just,
I just want to play a little last rights.
You know,
if you don't have a fucking solution, don't bring up the goddamn problem. Okay?
Like I brought the Connor McGregor Mayweather,
alright?
I said it's a fucking problem. I gave you your solution.
You drive on the highway 90 miles an hour and you turn the buffalo wild wings
into a gas chamber. See that? See that? I'm a good guy.
Everybody else is an idiot in my world. I'm the smartest person in the,
sorry. Well we went for the fuck. Do you want for me? You know,
watching my kid all day today, my wife's fucking tired. He,
I can't type in my God damn password. I'm not watching it now,
obviously while I'm doing the, the podcast.
But that's only because I curse so much.
I'm trying not to do that in front of her,
which I know I'm going to fail fucking miserably. Um,
do I get to take something to be like being a dad is just shit. It really is.
I fucking love it. It's, the best thing about it is watching kids shows,
I dunno if I'm a fucking moron or whatever, but I am legitimately entertained.
We started watching cars this morning. It's tremendous. I mean,
you know what it is. I haven't watched cartoons. It's so fucking long.
It's like the level of animation on those things. It's crazy.
Like I think I saw one of those toy stories, one or two of them.
But you know, when, when you, when you don't have a kid, it's like, you know,
why would you go see one of those
unless you smoke weed? Like, hey man, let's get high and go see fucking toys,
man. Right. Or, you know, you're dating a woman.
They always like seeing those. They're cute.
I like to message and he ended up going there and you just sit in there.
I just fucking, um, I remember I saw one of those toys stories,
like they were going down something and they will all get this conveyor belt and
they went into a pit of flames and the level of fucking anxiety that it brought
me, I got like angry at the movie. Like, this is a fucking kid's movie.
I shouldn't be feeling this way.
Why do I care so much about these goddamn toys? Um,
which is one of the reasons why I don't watch movies is because I,
I take the fucking ride.
You know, when people watch scary movies, they go to,
that movie didn't scare me. They all scare the fuck out of me cause I just, I,
I take the fucking ride.
Okay.
I never just, I never fucking pull myself out and look around the theater.
Gonads, it's just a movie. There's no reason to get this fucking upset.
This is stupid. That's just an actor. I want how many takes they did.
I don't do that. I get sucked in and it's fucking over.
It's fucking over.
And then I ended up getting freaked out and I walked to my car,
you know, and I'm thinking of the fucking Blair, which is going to get me. Um,
all right. I think I've, I think I babbled long enough here. Let's,
let's do a little bit of a, let's do lose some advertising.
Let's get to actually the funniest part of the podcast.
Me Trying to read out loud. All right. Frame. Bridge everybody. Okay.
Oh, you know what?
Frame Bridge Evidentaly is the easiest way to custom frame your favorite art and
photos. Is it we can't, you know,
you don't have the easiest ways that you give it to your partner.
Could you do me a huge favor and handle this big pain in the ass fucking job?
Um,
but if you're actually cool and you don't want to do that to your wife or your
husband or your fucking transgendered person, whatever,
I'm trying to be politically correct or whatever the fuck you're living with,
maybe a real Gore phobic and asexual
split personality. Don't do it together. Person in you. Okay?
Did I cover everybody? Um,
without ever leaving your house with their simple online ordering process,
you can order a fully customized piece in minutes. Here's how it works.
Go to Frame bridge.com upload your photo from your computer or directly from
your Instagram feed.
Have you met the Jordan Lailey or if you have a physical item,
they'll provide secure prepaid packaging so you can mail it in for free.
Preview your photo online in any frame or style.
Choose your favorite or get help for free.
Free help from the talented designers,
the expert team at frame bridge will custom frame your item in days,
not weeks or months, and deliver your finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang now? Now this was me. I am the copy here. Honestly,
how much longer can you talk about photos in a fucking frame,
but not that these guys do. They're going to keep going.
The best part you may not have asked.
Instead of the hundred you pay at framing stores,
their prices start at just $39 39 Sam Cunningham and all shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their first order@framebridge.com when they
use my code burr. All right gifts. He needed to know how much it costs.
Frame Bridge even offers a happiness guarantee.
If for any reason you aren't 100% satisfied with your order,
they'll make it right. Well then you should have a satisfaction guarantee,
not a happiness.
We have a happiness guarantee that if you're not 100% satisfied,
that doesn't make any sense. If you're not 100% of happiness, right?
Happiness guarantee, if you will, for any reason,
aren't 100% happy with your order. They'll make it right
now. Jesus, give your personal experience using framers.
I never fucking used it. I need you guys.
I never know why I don't have every fucking photo I've took in the last 20
years. I don't even know where it is.
It's on a hard drive in the back of my closet and I took so many fucking
pictures of shit. Like what are you gonna even use it for the site,
the ease of order and how your piece turned out and how easy and affordable it
was. Get started today. Framing your photos or art do,
they should have a fucking website, a useless cell phone picks.
You know those ones you just have.
You took a screenshot of something because you needed to remember a phone number
and then like months later you're scrolling back trying to find that picture.
You when you got on the hang glider and one of the photos,
you got to scroll past this,
the fucking one 800 number for the smokey Robinson cds, you know,
I don't know.
Would that be funny to sit there and look at the top 10 worthless cell phone
photos of the day and then people would do it on purpose so it probably be cool
for like a month. All right, go to frame bridge.com and use Promo code bar.
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order.
Just go to frame bridge.com Promo Code Bur frame bridge.com promo code bar.
That's classic advertising. Read the last time you do it.
You have that tone frame. [inaudible] dot com everything's gonna be all right.
All right. He looks everybody your unique. You know,
walk like everyone else. Talk like everyone else.
Show Chad sleep like everyone else. So why is your mattress?
Why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because a truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now. I can't believe that's the right number.
Go to helicase.com answer a few simple questions and they'll run.
Do you sleep on your back or you sleep on your Dick?
And they'll run a 3d biomechanical model of your body through their proprietary
algorithms they've developed with the help of the world's leading arrogant
nomics and mechanic experts. The results our robot shows up to the door,
punches you in the face through the mattress that you ordered and becomes you.
Sorry. The most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Helix customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality and for
couples, they customize each side of the mattress.
That's the end of the relationship right there.
You're starting to build separate lives.
Your mattress arrives at your door and about a week in shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are all talking about Helleck
sleep. You have a hundred nights to try it out. If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free and you have a 100% refund.
No questions asked. Go to helix, sleep.com/burn and get $50 off your order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bar hey,
he looks sleep.com/burn one of those pronunciations is right.
Oh my God, everybody. It's dollar shave club.
Do Dollar Shave Club is this smarter choice why you might've asked.
You'll get a great shave at a great price.
Conveniently delivered right to your [inaudible]. You going be set for life.
Kid, you no longer have to Schlep to this store.
Buy Cheap disposable races that give you a cheap shave or spend a fortune on
races with gimmicky shaving technology you don't even fucking need.
And when you use dollar Shave Club's executive razor with the doctor,
the cabbies easy, the blade gently glides,
giving you a smooth shave as you travel across your ball bag.
Dr Carver's shave butter is transparent for a more precise shave,
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights razor bumps. So in other words,
it works for white people and black people make the smarter choice by going to
do I only shave club for a limited time.
New members get their first month of the executive razor with a tube of their Dr
Carver's shave butter for only $5 with free shipping. After that,
the raises are just a few bucks a month.
That's 15 that's a $15 value for only five bucks.
There's no hidden fees and no commitments cancel anytime you like.
You can only get this offer exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com slash burger that's
dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] I fucking love those guys just for the simple
fact that it's just one paragraph. They have empathy for me, I feel.
All right, one more.
Can you guys handle me reading out loud a wink,
W I N C or is it wink?
It is Winz whiskey India. November. Charlie. Uh,
when you have a great clap, when you have a great glass of wine,
it enhances the moment.
Whether you're reflecting on the day or with someone you love or just overly
explaining something to three people who are,
have been bored with you for 20 minutes depending on how drunk you are.
Wink understands this.
It's why they started their company to give you access to exceptional wines from
around the world.
So you have more of those moments of being drunk around your children. A No,
I'm just kidding. Nobody who drinks wine is a women.
Do women drink wine after they put the kids down, right?
And they pull it out a fucking bite.
The cork off like a fucking pirate. And you know what? God bless them.
They deserve to do that. Just try winc.com spelled t, r, y,W ,
I N c.com.
Try winc.com take a brief palate profile quiz and wink will recommend distinct
and interesting,
interesting wines actually customized to your pallet to be shipped directly to
your door every month. Isn't it hilarious that you can do this with alcohol?
You can never do this with like crack cocaine, you know,
take a brief palate profile quiz and we'll get you the crack pipe that best fits
your lips.
None of your time is wasted fitting in a run to the store or on your way home
from work or on your way to an event or gathering.
No more time spent guessing what you might like. That's actually great.
That's not the worst as an adult when you go over a couples, you know,
should we bring anything now we're all good. You know,
you got to bring a bottle of wine,
then you've got to stop at the fucking door of the store to pain in the ass.
Just stock up on booze with try winc.com because wink basis the blind stay sent.
They send you on your tastes preferences, wink.
We'll even introduce you to new rare and custom wines that are not available
anywhere else and tell you the story behind each one. Join for free.
Skip any month,
cancel any time and have a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee so you never
have to pay for a bottle you don't like. And right now,
Winc is offering listeners $20 off your first order.
When you go to try winc.com/burr they'll even cover the cost of shipping.
Let's try winc.com spelled t r y w I N c.com/bar to get $20 off your first
order, plus complimentary shipping. Let's try winc.com/bar all right.
What are we up to? 34 fucking minutes. Oh, you know what?
I didn't even talk about the f one race. Did you guys watch it?
Did you check it out? Louis Hamilton closing the gap.
Only down by one point. Catching up on Sebastian Vettel.
What happened to the Ferrari's out there in fucking Great Britain
or was it Kimmie raking in whatever his fucking name is, he's driving,
he's in third place. He's loving life for second place,
whatever he was in his front tire bough fucking blows out with like fucking four
or five laps to go and then he fucking gets on the radio. The towns,
they're like Gaba B man. He goes to for the fucking front to tie. Right.
So he's got to go in Vettel moves up.
He's going to be on the podium as much as fucking a Lewis.
Hamilton's going to pick up 25 points.
He's going to pick up at least fucking 15, if not 18. Right. Who knows?
You know, and all of a sudden fucking two laps ago,
his fucking tire goes up front left one. Right. And then all the towns,
you're like, mom, mommy. Yeah. Right. And fucking Vettel's all God damn pissed.
I think I have. I think I know who my favorite fucking driver is though.
I liked that. I,
how have you seen his first name? Black Veltin. Valtteri uh,
[inaudible] that guy. That guy can fucking drive.
He went from ninth place all the way to second place.
Now I know I've talked about Lewis Hamilton and these guys go in from fucking,
you know, nights like, uh, what's his face yesterday?
The Australian fucking dude, they're the good,
the happiest guy in fucking Formula One. Uh, uh, Jesus Christ by,
I swear to God up and all the fucking names in front of me.
You know what as it said, raking in, there's too many Rs.
There's too many fucking like crazy fucking the nerve of these people
[inaudible] from like other cultures is, it was a date is a Dave. They fucking a
Jesus guy. I only met the fucking guy. I've only been rooting for them.
Daniel Ricardo. There we go.
The fuck it would pop back into my head as much as those guys have gone from
like 19th to fucking, you know, seventh or eighth,
the 15th to whatever it is.
I think it's harder to go from ninth all the way up to second because you get
into like the best of the best drivers to fucking go pass driver number five,
four three to get all the way up to that.
Starting as far back as he did with the Mercedes. Once again,
having a gearbox issue.
That's what happens with Mercedes state fabric gearbox issue.
When they get a five spot fucking penalty and evidentaly I don't know who the
fuck it is that's supposed to be working on that fucking shock absorber on the
front left hand side of the car where the fin or the fucking tire,
whatever the fuck it is. One of those guys.
Where are the underoos with the helmet on in the pit.
Somebody back there is getting a fucking,
he's getting no pasta this week on the Ferrari team. So, um,
what's his face? Vettel was up by like, I don't know how many fucking points.
Um, I forgot what place he came in.
I think he got like six or eight points and he was up by like t he was up by 20
points before the race started. I can do the math here.
And by the end of the race, he was only up by one. Uh,
this is like a fucking math test. So Lewis Hamilton got 25 points,
so he outscored him by fucking 24. So what do you come in? 10th Place?
He got one point. No, that'd be 24.
He got four points. All right, so he came in, he came in like eighth, right?
I think he came in eighth. All right. Whatever. Why,
why the fuck would you care?
So they got one more race before they take the break in the summertime.
Like they're like their lives on fucking great enough. They're part of like,
like literally 20 people who can do this in the fucking universe. All right.
They get to take the fucking summer off. I'm like, these poor bastards.
I played fucking baseball who got to pay like fucking six to seven games a
goddamn week. You know, these guys get to take the summer off.
Granted the you have to still diet, you know, but you know,
even if they have like a shake, then they can, they can fucking get rid of it.
Bang in a supermodel, you know, fuck sweat it out of them. I mean,
their lives are unbelievable. Louis Hamilton and fucking, uh,
what's his face? Botox. They both live in Monaco. It's unbel. It's like,
it's not enough that you get know he's got the private jet.
Like these fucking guys lives are unbelievable. It's fucking tremendous.
God bless them. Hey, what's going on with the fucking,
the other red bull team that's not red bull. The blue ones. The fucking
what the hell? What the, what did they do that the Toro Rosso fucking team,
whatever the fuck they're called. Jesus Christ.
They were doing their impression of the force India team fucking slamming into
each other. I love when that happens. I love that.
And reminds me that fucking a, that movie stepbrothers.
They doing like the Formula One version of putting their balls on will Ferrell's
drum kit. Oh No, he put it on the other guy's drum kit. That's right.
I don't know. Anyways, let's get to the fucking questions this week.
Um,
oh, by the way, all things comedies own Iresha fears, new double Netflix,
special airs Tuesday [inaudible],
um,
July 18th, both double negative, uh, both, uh,
both double negative children and double negative adulthood will be available in
190 countries. That's incredible, Huh? The reach,
the sheer reach of Netflix. All right. Feminism. Everybody.
Let's do some fucking reets here for the Goddamn Week. Shall We?
I got 20 minutes left here in this fucking podcast. Um,
all right. Feminism.
Bill a on a recent podcast when discussing stewardesses and air travel,
you mentioned that you sometimes thing,
I think you meant to say think feminism
is a way for ugly women to get jobs that attractive women used to have.
I said that. Why do you guys take anything? I say seriously? You understand?
I'm just riffing for a fucking hour and I'm trying to make you laugh by saying
ridiculously over the top things somebody's going to write me in a few weeks ago
. Hey Bill, a few weeks ago on your podcast,
you suggested turning buffalo wild wings into gas chambers.
On the night of the Mayweather McGregor fight. Uh, just to let you know,
I am a parent. I am not a fight fan,
but I do enjoy the fucking Jalapeno balls,
whatever the fuck they're called
at buffalo wild wings. And what if I was there anyways?
Um,
I wonder if, okay, you,
I Vanilli I said that feminism is a way for ugly women to get jobs that
attractive women used to have. That's fucking hilarious.
I don't necessarily believe that, but there is an element of truth to that.
Like, you know, when they are always bitching, like, you know,
Hollywood creates this impossible image of beauty. It's like, no,
you can't. You can't.
Okay.
You, your fear of fucking EGOMANIAC. I don't think,
when I look at a Brad Pitt or whoever the fucking guy is now,
Brad Pitt's like in his fifties now, so wherever the fucking shredded,
who's the guy from say by the belt? Mario Lopez. You know when I don't,
when I looked at him with his pigment at his fucking abs and all that,
I don't fucking go, God, this is an impossible fucking oh Jesus,
this is an impossible standard for me to,
to a standard for me to hold up to and therefore Mario Lopez should be on
fucking TV anymore. I just understand that. Yeah. You know what?
On a good day, maybe I'm a six. Okay. That's what I am.
Not Everybody can bet clean up in the order. Okay. If you fucking bad nature,
quit your crying and get on base. That's it.
Maybe I do believe that on some level anyways,
I wonder if you know that this is actually rush Limbaugh's undeniable truth of
life number 24 specifically that feminism was established so as to allow
unattractive women to access access to the mainstream of society.
Um, here's the thing I'm saying this shit,
I'm like 90% joking.
There's always like an element of truth that guy as far as I could tell,
cause I don't know what his act is. It might all just be an act, you know,
so he can eat cause he is in show business. So I have no idea.
It could just be an act. But if you actually truly believe that I don't,
I listen, I don't believe that. Okay. Um,
feminism came about because men were not allowing women to pursue their dreams.
Okay.
But like any cause any cause for whatever reason along the way,
a lot of the times you end up becoming what the fuck you have fighting. Okay.
And that's not this unique thought. I realized that's a hacky thought,
but it's fucking true.
The level of bullying that goes on on the Internet and trying to get people to
get fired and trying to create firestorms and trying to,
trying to show the power of women buy a lot of times attacking people who you're
deliberately and knowingly taking what they said out of context and causing them
to not have a fucking job is fucking reprehensible. All right.
And they in a lot of ways do the same Reptilian,
if the ends justify the means corporate fucking mentality,
just some of the shit that that is set out there. Um, yeah, look, I,
I don't think that it's actually that, but sometimes they think it's that,
you know, there are jobs that you should only get if you're good looking.
You know, I, I really believe that like, uh, like when when you, you know,
the first person that they're going to fucking walk in the top of your order,
you got to go with Ricky Henderson. You know,
you gotta get somebody who's going to get on base,
you're gonna put the fucking picture up. You know?
And I, I feel like I can say this because of how I look. Mike,
if I ran a company, I'm not putting me on the front desk.
Like I'm the first person you're going to say, why would you do that?
We're trying to make money here. You know,
I don't like high schools over, look in the mirror, love yourself,
but I have a sense of humor about yourself. Know that you're not perfect.
And just know that it's okay. And you know what?
A lot of times if you steer into that shit and you have a sense of humor about
yourself, you're fun to be around. How many times do I call myself a pasty,
bald, freckled fucking jackass telling you,
you fucking stare into it and you fucking age gracefully. All right?
You start to lose your fucking hair.
You just shave you fucking head and just be that guy. Everybody's like,
what the fuck and that. But you know what? You deal with the that people fought,
they respect Ya. Okay, this guy came down the pike.
He didn't even try to shake it off.
He took the pitch right to the side of the head area.
Is he standing on first base? Good for you. You ugly bald son of a bitch,
right? And this is the thing too. I know that they need us,
we bald son of a bitches in movies and I'll just audition for that.
At the end of the fucking day, I'm in a movie. Am I really going to complain?
You know, I feel fucking
fucking bald. Freckled red head should be starring, right. More movies.
It's like, Oh yeah, you want to put your money,
put your money where your mouth is, you go finance that fucking movie. Uh,
yeah. And a lot of ways,
that's one of those things where it's everybody should get like a, a, a ribbon.
I mean, I don't know what the solution is, but you like,
competition is a good thing. Okay. And the best,
you know, the best should, should win.
Right?
Mike? I'm, I'm,
I'm all with it as far as everybody should have the same opportunity,
but after that, go fuck yourself. Whoever's the best gets it,
you know, not like, well,
we have enough of these people or enough of those know who are the fucking best.
Okay. When we have to keep doing that, because at some point,
if the aliens aren't already here, they're coming here and we,
we need to have an all star fucking team,
not a team that makes everybody feel represented. All right, Dan, we go.
I hope I explained myself or you know, I'll,
I'll know if I'm right if I don't get a call from the rush Limbaugh show asking
me if I want to be a guest. Alright.
Brother x feminine. Dear Billy Boyo,
a relative, relatively new fan here. I love humor. My tea.
Love your material and I hope to see you live one day. I'll thank you.
Before I start,
I want to say that I don't care if my brother is gay to each his own is my
motto. Okay. Now for the back story. There you go. That's what I do.
You've established,
you've given yourself credibility because you said that you're a good person.
All right. I'm 17 about to be a senior in high school.
My brother is 11 and is about to start middle school.
I feel like other kids will view him as an easy target for a few reasons. First,
he doesn't have many guy friends and he hangs out with a lot of ladies. Second,
I do. I try to do masculine things with them. I played baseball,
so I always ask him to play catch with me and I even offered to teach him how to
play the sport.
He usually says no when I try to do any sort of physical activity with them.
He rejects my requests and just does his own thing. Third,
his body language is quite feminine. He sits like a girl,
talks like a girl and moves his hands like a girl. You know what I'm saying?
And the thing that ladies and gay guys do with their hands, oh,
you know what I'm saying?
The thing that ladies and gay guys do with their hands when they talk,
my gut tells me to sit down and have a talk with him,
but I don't want to come off too blunt and hurt his feelings. Then again,
that could be what he needs. A, I think if I tell him what I'm thinking,
he'll just blow it off just like me. He's very hot headed.
I'm sorry about the hyphen.
I personally blame his behavior on the pussification of society over the past
few years and the very progressive environment of modern day schooling.
He's a good kid and he's got a good head on his shoulders.
So I'm not worried about anything else. I'm just looking out for them.
I don't want any dickheads messing with him. I used to get bullied,
so I know how it feels. What do you thinks, uh,
thanks for your help and go fuck yourself. All right.
I think you're 17 and I think you love your brother and you're trying to protect
him.
Um, here's the deal dude. Uh,
I mean your brother is who your brother is. You got to accept that.
And um,
I don't know how you handle the bullying thing,
which is I what I really think is what you see when you look at your brother's
like this kid's going to get the shit kicked out of them.
Um,
which is, uh, you know, sad to say, you know,
hopefully not as much as when I was coming up, but yeah,
that is, uh, that is a, it's a legit concern. Um,
but, um,
I don't think you listen, people are born how they're born. Okay.
I don't know if this kid's gay or not. I don't know what,
but if he doesn't want to play catch, he doesn't want to play catch.
And if he's hot headed, you know, he sounded, he said he's a smart kid,
he's hothead, he knows what he wants.
So just let him be himself and you support them.
And there is no reason why this kid, he doesn't like to do physical shit.
I was gonna say, take him down to with Dojo,
teach them how to fuck somebody up and um,
the fact that he is a feminine, if he goes and fuck somebody up,
that's going to be humiliating for the other person and then nobody else is
gonna want to fuck with them cause they don't want to get beat up by him.
Bruce Lee used to do that. Bruce Lee used to, I've read this book,
used to walk around and he would act all the feminine and then these guys would
come up and fuck with them and then he would kick the shit out of him.
People ask them, well why would you do that? He said, well,
if I just walked up like a regular dude, you know, they got their ass kicked,
they could get over it. But if, you know,
they thought they got their ass kicked by his sissy, you know,
it stays with them. And unfortunately that is something with guys, if,
if you know, if people were more progressive or whatever the fucking word is,
they wouldn't think that. And they'd just be like, well,
it doesn't make a difference if you're a feminine or masculine.
If you can fucking throw hands over there with a couple of feet seas,
I can, I can accept a loss.
Um,
I listen, I would just, uh, if anything,
I would try to have a closer relationship with my younger brother and um,
and I would ask him how his days are going and I would just literally ask him,
has anybody at school fucking with you or whatever. And uh,
if they are, I don't know. I would go down and have a fucking till.
I don't know if he could do that. I don't know what to do. I Dunno what to do.
But that would, that as an older brother that would kill me,
knowing that somebody could be fucking with my younger brothers.
So I think you come from a good place, uh, your ideas of, uh,
you know how to cure him of that are understandable because you're 17.
I don't think it's society's fault. Um, I,
I just think that's just how he's born. And I think if you accept it,
he will accept it and he'll keep a, a good feeling about himself. But,
um,
unfortunately the bullying is going to come and he's going to have to learn how
to stick up for himself. I mean, that's just the truth of it. And, um,
okay.
There's all kinds of things that you could do that I'm not allowed to say on the
podcast as far as what he could do in those moments because somehow I become
this fucking bad person. But, uh,
I'm just going to tell a random story here.
I remember what show the late Charlie Murphy rest his soul.
He told me to do what to do if you ever go to jail. And I just,
he was like, you know, not let, I could still survive.
He just like, Yo, this is what you do. He goes,
the first motherfucker that steps to you, he goes,
you just turn into a wild animal fraud than at the mouth and you just fucking
swing for the fences and everybody, you know what I,
I'm over simplifying what the fuck he said. And um,
you know, that's just a story he told me.
That has nothing to do with what I just fucking read. Okay.
I want to do that so I stay free and clear. I don't know what to tell you buddy.
All right. Uh, let him be who he is and um, you know,
I would watch some MMA events with them and maybe he'll want to learn how to
fucking do it. I Dunno. I Dunno. Cause I watched some,
some cool videos of some kids that were way out of their own way class.
This one fucking kid. Fuck this kid up, jumped up, put them in a fucking arm.
This kid, he didn't know what the fuck to do. Um,
maybe you can help them out with that, but uh, yeah,
I would let go of all that other shit that you're going to fucking, I mean, if,
if like your be who you are. I mean, if somebody,
when you go out in the driveway and,
and still learn how to twirl a baton just would still
be you. But you'd know how to twirl a baton.
I don't think it would change how you walked or behaved or who you hung out
with. Um, you're wired how you wired. All right. Uh,
girlfriend wants to move back to her home.
That's like those fucking people that, you know,
they would try to cure gay people. You know, they think that they can, like,
it's a, like they have the mumps or something,
a girlfriend wants to move back to her home country. Uh,
all right.
Hey, Bill Hill. If the guy took the woman's last name in marriage, that's funny.
All right. Longtime listener. First Time advice seeker. I live in London.
I met my girlfriend online a year and a half ago. She's 25 and I'm 24.
She's from Switzerland. See this is what happens now.
All these fucking dating apps, fun fact about Switzerland,
they have enough nuclear bunkers to accommodate their entire population.
Uh, yeah. This because they're so close to fucking Germany. Um,
they moved here a few years ago to get a music. Uh,
she moved here a few years ago to get a music degree in. Graduated,
graduated last year. She was going to move in with a friend a few months ago,
but her best friend did a one 80 at the last second.
So we decided to move in together as we enjoy each other's company.
Here's the shit part.
She always said that she misses her family and her friends a lot,
which is of course understandable.
But recently she's been mentioning that she wants to move back to Switzerland
once our lease is up next year. I completely get why she want to do this.
She doesn't have many friends here,
a as many over college friends have moved back home.
The thing is,
I have established an established career here and I don't want to leave my
friends or job behind to go move to a country where I don't speak the language
I've tried, but there are hardly any courses for Swiss. Slash. German.
Okay.
I'm in the market for my skills is much smaller.
I'm a magician and academic tutor,
Jesus is a fucking Combo. Uh, whenever she brings it up,
I answer with very variations of, well, uh,
we'll cross that bridge when we come to it,
but I'm pretty sure I'm never going to come around to the idea.
She has made the point a couple of times that this would be me choosing my
career and friends over her, which makes it sound worse than it is.
What should I tell her?
Thanks and go fuck yourself while she's choosing her country and her family over
you. So I would say nicely, listen,
you keep saying that this is me choosing my career
and you know, what'd just want you to say Mike and Friends over her?
Um,
do you know that feeling you have when you live here in London?
That's what I'm going to feel like when I'm in Switzerland.
Do you want me to feel that? No. Well good. I don't want to feel that either.
So one of us has to make a sacrifice here.
Are you willing to live here? And if she says no,
then you have to be willing to live there. And if you're not willing to do that,
then you guys need to break up. It's simple as that.
Simple as that. Um,
I would, I would fucking, that's it dude. You know, you got to fucking,
yeah,
Goddamn kids today, you know, fucking swiping left and XNL. Yeah.
My girlfriend lives in fucking Bangladesh and as she's really missing some of
the food over there and I, you know, and I fucking, you know,
whatever the fuck I do over here, I mean these are,
these are like modern day relationship fucking problems. Yeah, that's it.
One of you guys has to move,
but don't let her guilt you and she not choosing her and her friends,
you're doing what she's doing.
You're living where you want to live next to the people you love and you can't
get mad at her for wanting to do the exact same thing. All right? But you know,
she's trying to mind. Fuck. You know, for me, I,
you feel like you're choosing this. Go Fuck Yourself. All right,
well go back home then. Send me some chocolates.
We'll bang every once in awhile. We'll meet in Paris. How about that?
That's it. I don't know what to tell you.
All right, girlfriend, you, you came to my place, not the other way around. Uh,
girlfriends, belly hangs, pastor tits out. Jesus.
[inaudible]
hey there. Hey there. Billy Willy freckled cheeks. Love the podcast.
Especially when you and Nia do the podcast so that I know,
and I gotta get her around here more,
but it's just like when I do what she has to watch the kid and the other way
around. All right, I got a problem then.
I'm hoping you and Nia may be able to help you with.
I love my wife of seven years dearly. We have fun together,
make each other laugh, et cetera. She's my best friend.
We're an in her early thirties, have no children and are very affluent,
crushing it except for the sex.
The sex is bad because we have become fatty fat fats.
We've been together for a decade. Uh,
and this has only become a problem over the past six months.
I'm five 11 and two 40 with a lot of muscle and a lot of fat. She's five,
four and 200 and has no muscle mass.
I'm ashamed to say that even though I love her fiercely,
she's no longer physically attractive to me. Well, I mean, what the fuck?
Let me just being honest, I'm sure you're not as attracted to her,
although you did give yourself some props for having a little bit of muscle.
You didn't quite say you was as big a mess. I'm ashamed to say that he, okay.
Um, she probably feels to say okay. If he said that she probably feels the same.
She used to be one 40 tops and was curving and all the right places.
I used to be cut like a Greek God. Our sex life was amazing.
She'd have one to three orgasms. Jesus Christ.
Every time we had sex one to three times per weeks and now maybe we have sex
once a month. She can't climb anymore because she gets too tired. Jesus,
over the past six weeks, I've cut 10 pounds and exercise six times a week.
I'm trying, but I have a long way to go.
She hasn't tried to eat right and is not interested in exercising with me.
I know sex tends to dwindle over time,
but I'd like for us to be in good enough shape that we don't need a
nitroglycerine pill every we try to do the dirt.
Any advice would be much appreciated. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
You have to sit down and have an honest conversation with her. Okay.
I would leave the sex life out of it.
It's just like she's not going to live long. All right. Um,
it five, four, 200 pounds. Uh,
maybe you could start by going for quote romantic walks and a,
you hold her hand. Didn't need you try to pick up the pace and drag along.
I would just, yeah, I would talk to her, um, about it. And,
uh, if she chooses not to get in shape,
then I w I would not alter what you're doing.
I would go back to being the Greek God that you were. And um,
if she doesn't want to get in shape, then you know, what are you supposed to do?
Watch her eat herself into an early fucking grave.
You supposed to be with somebody that you're not sexually attracted to anymore.
I mean, that, that's fair man.
If somebody puts on almost like she put on almost half her body weight.
Yeah.
I mean, that's not a, that's not fair.
It's not fair to yourself and it's not fair to the person you're in.
You gotta be making an effort to, to, to still look good. You know,
when people have a tendency, men and women to do that, to become, you know,
do you know, just walking around fucking shitty looking clothes,
just being a tub of shit and it's just like that whole,
you should accept me for whatever I am.
That means I'm going to be the least of who I could be.
Nobody ever says that when they're there the best. Yeah.
I'd like to accept you fucking going to the Goddamn Gym. Same Way.
You'd like me to not fucking have my belly hanging down past my junk. Um, yeah,
I'd have a conversation with her. Just sit down at, you know what? Maybe a,
my beautiful daughter is asleep. Maybe uh, Nia could come in and help.
Hang on a second. Let me hit pause here. Yeah. She can't do it. She can't do it.
Sorry. Sorry to get your goddamn hopes up. So, uh, just know that, um,
that you just got advice from a guy.
So what I would do is I would ask a woman in your life,
not her advice on how to, how to drop in. Okay.
Cause this is one of these relationship conversations.
It's like when a spaceship is reentering the atmosphere of the space shuttle,
that if it wasn't at the right fucking angle, you know,
well you lost a couple of those fucking shingles on the bottom.
You could fucking burn up on reentry. All right.
Did I really have to bring up that tragedy to make my point. I don't know.
Maybe I didn't. All right. Girlfriend has severe halitosis Jesus Christ.
The women are getting destroyer ladies. Ladies, you got to write in next week,
okay? You got to write in next week. Okay.
Stop being sweethearts and tell me what the problem is with the guys. This is,
this is not fair and balanced like Fox News
or CNN. Um,
I love that chick that cried on CNN, the one with the Mary Lou Retton haircut.
When Trump got elected. It's just like,
there was one of the most unprofessional journalistic moments
I've ever seen in my fucking life. How did we go from Walter Cronkite to that?
Like, I literally know who you voted for. You're not a journalist. All right.
Hey, their op ed piece. All right. Girlfriend has severe halitosis.
Dear Billy Bats, I saw you perform at hilarides in the land.
The worst fucking nickname. The land.
The land of what? Jesus Christ. That's so fucking bad.
And you had me in stitches. Please come back the land.
They had tee shirts back there. Defend the land.
Do you know for half a second in Boston, they split.
They lose people calling it the bean, which said, don't do that.
Beantown was bad enough. We don't make beans there anymore.
Any more than Porchester still makes fucking lifesavers,
although grand rapids still makes furniture. Um,
I can't. Anyways, I'm 23 year old man and recently began dating a girl.
I met on a dating app. We've been on two dates and she has bad breath.
Dumper Jesus Christ over the fuck. Do you care?
It's not your problem. Anyways,
you've been on two dates so far and they both went great.
We went to a couple of museums for how far away were you standing from her?
Were you standing there going, uh, is that our breadth of the artifacts?
Is that our breadth of that fucking Willy Mammas statue that they dug out of the
fucking ice 2000 years ago anyways?
Well actually willy man was for fucking 4 billion BC. Go Fuck Yourself.
All right. We have a good conversation in this great chemistry overall,
but when she smiles,
the sight and smell indicates years of not brushing or flossing. Dude,
I don't know. I don't even know the fact that you need advice on this.
There is thick, dark yellow buildup a longer gumline Oh my God,
I'm going to Puke and she talks loud so her breath travels a long way.
Kissing is difficult to enjoy.
Oh my God, this is gross.
Okay.
I almost just gagged there.
I almost just gagged there dude.
What kind of fucking low self esteem do you have? What is my advice?
Either break up with her or take her to one of those self power washes,
car wash things and tell her to smile in fucking blast or right in the fucking
grill. Okay. Jesus fucking Christ.
That's the most disgusting visual.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What is my advice? I don't know what.
You know what I might advice it states they should make a stamp for you cause
you're a God damn saint.
Oh my God.
Kissing is difficult.
Ugh,
I've got, I think I got to walk this one off. Buddy did.
Does plenty of fucking fish in the fucking seat.
[inaudible]
Jesus. Oh my God. That's okay. I'm gonna to, speaking of fish,
that's like having a Goddamn eel going along your goddamn gum lines.
I'm sorry guys. I don't know why. Yeah, dude, I would just, that's it.
It's over. I, there should be. No, no.
I mean you're going to hang in there with this one. What the fuck do you say?
Hey, what are you doing Thursday night? No, nothing.
You want to go to the dentist?
Let's get his or her cleanings.
Oh my God, Dude. If, if, if that looks like that, what is,
what is the fucking basement gonna look like, Dude. Oh my God.
Okay.
Oh my God. Hey God bless you dude. Yeah, I get her to a dentist.
However the fuck you bring that up. I don't know. Some questions are beyond me.
All right. Jesus Christ. All right. That's the, uh,
I've never had to stop reading an email before.
I haven't done that. I haven't them come that close to puke.
And since opie and Anthony, the baby bird when I was in that fucking room,
and I still to this day,
could not tell that story without fucking gagging and coughing.
And if you puke easily, do not fucking go look up opie and Anthony. Baby Bird.
All right. That's it. That's the podcasts. Go fuck yourselves.
I will check in on you on Thursday.
I am back to watching a little bit of baseball.
I did miss the a Yankees don't care. I was working the whole weekend.
I think the Yankees got the better of us. I know we did one game.
Yankees are in third and the fucking devil race. I'm moving up there.
Only a half a game out.
So I'm gonna try to watch what playing the fuck's in Toronto. Blue Jays. Bam,
Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam. Fucking um, Toronto Blue Jays there.
That was my reference to a whatever that fucking song is by rush.
That is the Morse code. Y,
Y,Z for Toronto's airport. Somehow they came up with a guitar. Riff for that.
All right. That's something Kevin Murphy would try to do on F is for family.
Huh? Season too on Netflix. Look at that. Coming out of that disgusting story.
Promoting his show. Telling you to go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.